to you all and we will dive
straight in
the first question concerns some of the
issues that are behind
these strikes it asks what are the
safety issues that striking workers are
concerned about simon calderon say you
know it's a hodgepodge of issues isn't
it it certainly is so let's tackle
safety and this is something that the
rmt has
really continued to to pursue they say
that network rail is wanting to adopt
procedures which use fewer staff and are
more dangerous and so therefore they say
that this is a really important part of
it now i know that the culture of safety
in the railways just like in aviation is
absolutely obsessive and there's no way
that anybody on the railway would
tolerate an increase in risk and so
therefore
the certainly discussions to be had
about how you can improve things and of
course the railway side network rail is
saying actually if you use modern
techniques we can actually make the
railways safer than they are now
particularly for the staff who are
working on them but it's just an example
of the enormous intransigence that there
is today um grant schnapps mentioned the
fact that
sunday working has been a kind of
optional an overtime thing for the last
103 years and that just shows you the
kinds of uh agreements that were that
are in place but of course there's been
quite a lot of different transport
secretaries in that time who could have
done something about that if they wanted
to okay uh next question just to kick us
off sorry you have this one
will the strike impact rail journeys for
the rest of the week as well as strike
days because it's at the moment it's one
day off one day on but presumably there
are knock-on effects to the days when
the trains are meant to be running so
the first one's wednesday that's right
the railway is a massively complex
organization and so you to expect
disruption for the whole rest of the
week going into the weekend which is
going to impact people not just
traveling for work but also for leisure
and as we know we've got glastonbury
this weekend as well aha we've got a
question about that coming up but um so
i mean the knock-on effect being i
suppose trains end up in the wrong
places and this and the staff to work in
them
so passengers are being warned to check
check and check again as we've heard and
that's absolutely the message um we
already know that we've spoken to about
2 000 people already just over the
weekend a representative sample and we
know that around three and five have got
the message and won't be planning to
travel but almost one in five still plan
to travel some of that is because they
absolutely have to they're the people
who kept the lights on during the
lockdown they're the ones who work in
our shops and schools and hospitals and
rely on the railway um although
surprisingly around one in ten were
actually still unaware of the strike
action though hopefully they've got the
message by now so just to add that there
will be lots and lots of trains running
tomorrow okay it's four and a half
thousand which is about 22 percent of
the normal
number but if you are lucky enough to
live in the half of the country that
does have railways as we heard nothing
west of cardiff if you're in scotland
nothing north of falkirk um that's a
really terrible uh situation but in the
rest of the country and again i'm afraid
it's london and the southeast will have
a perfectly kind of competent uh service
so it's well it's worth checking oh yeah
sure during the day from about half past
seven in the morning till about half
past six at night bear in mind the last
trains for example there's a train an
hour to cardiff um similar frequency to
bristol to birmingham to manchester uh
to leeds
there's a lot of trains running gatwick
airport um four trains an hour okay so
keep your keep your eyes peeled for that
term okay simon jones i want to put this
to you and this next question is about
well i suppose the finances
the mess that the finances are trained
tickets are already unbelievably high
ridership is low due to people working
for a moment we have a cost of living
crisis how can the rail industry survive
without a major overhaul and we know of
the scale of subsidies that the rail
industry gets
i think you're absolutely right uh rail
finances are not in a good place the
government
uh earmarked i think it was about 16
billion pound of uh emergency funding
just to balance the books that's that's
like 600 pound per family in the uk
or
160 000 pound for every worker in the
railways
and it's uh you know
when you look at it now and you see how
much ticket prices are
without the reform that the railways
need there is only one way and one set
of people that will be picking up the
cost
of pay increases and that will be the
traveling public um and
i think these strikes are just a act of
self-harm
you an average pay for an average worker
on the railways is about 55 000 pound a
year and someone a lot more somewhat a
lot less but
i think the union bosses are now
jeopardizing an industry that they say
and i know that the majority of people
that work on the industry love
okay but how how i mean what about this
the prices i mean i was recently on a
train more or less across the entirety
of germany from berlin to dusseldorf it
was about cost me about 80 euro i mean a
comparable distance in the uk would have
been you know on the day it was as well
would have been over 200 quid
and i think that's the big difference
isn't it that we have this myriad of
confusing ticket prices in the uk at the
moment and it's something which i know
the industry reforms with uh gbr
role reforms are supposed to address as
well but you can buy cheap tickets um
there was a recently a sale where some
of the tickets were
exceptionally low some of my friends
have dashed the million pound uh ticket
sale
look they are not consistent though and
if you rock up on the day you can pay
exceptionally high prices prices and
some people are forced into ticket
prices are very high they will put up
and they will pay for those prices as
long as the trains exist that is why i
think that this union action is so
disastrous because we've been through
that awful pandemic a period where
people didn't travel around uh but
people are starting to get the
confidence going back my train yesterday
back from suffolk uh was absolutely
heaving uh it was great to see people
back on the railway but
if they don't believe the trains are
going to show they won't be turning up
the ticket revenue will go and we won't
have the trains that we desperately need
in this country and someone else
adjusted i mean in terms of not just the
the high prices but the confusion about
meaning well where does it leave
passengers
very sorry
yeah i mean there's
millions of combinations of tickets it
is a really really complicated system i
work in the industry and i sometimes
have to ask colleagues for hand to work
out when i'm going on a long weekend
that said there are good deals available
and we are also going through a wide
scale reform of the industry uh the you
know the biggest in a generation where
there's an opportunity for government to
listen to what how passengers want to
live work and travel and provide
products that match that so we're
looking at single leg pricing to avoid
this you know return being a pound more
and pay as you go to make things that
are valuable yeah and price capping but
but i mean you know this reform that
we're talking about this is in part is
what's behind the strike attempt to
reform well you you absolutely need to
reform the industry to cut the
extraordinary cost of running trains but
you also need to reform the fair system
the government had the perfect
opportunity rail ridership fell to a
tiny number tiny percentage at that
point you could have just said right we
are going to completely readjust
everything the department for transport
the treasury shied away from that and i
am not convinced that they are going to
do what is necessary even though they
keep saying they are just to pick up on
a couple of things simon said first of
all
um in terms of earnings 55 000 average
earning on the railway well that i think
would be the
the the the level that drivers are on
drivers most drivers are not involved
they're not the vastness the rmt says um
that most of their members earn between
20 and 30 000 pounds some of them are on
minimum very important point to make
we're we're going in all these questions
we're going from big picture to the
specific and you can't get more specific
than this i don't know sarah would you
know this will reserve seating on
non-strike days still be valid uh well
simon cole has no idea
i mean good question and i'd say double
check with your opportunity because the
train might not be it should be if the
train is running but
the um train operators have done
everything they can to stop people
booking tickets effectively they've
taken advanced tickets off the whole
week and therefore that means if your
train is running and you've got a ticket
for it then it should be absolutely fine
for example lumo which is a new operator
running between london newcastle and
edinburgh is saying yep everyone's going
to have a seat available we're doing
quite a lot of running trains on strike
days on the days after you've got to
have a seat reservation um you can
organize that through us and they're
actually saying they're the only
operator i know of who's saying yeah
we're looking at stepping up the number
of trains we run on thursday and
saturday
new one on me sorry and just to add of
course um this isn't what he asked but
um if you have booked assistance if you
have mobility needs you do need to check
whether that's going to be available
yeah that's an issue with or without
strikes isn't it of course um question
for you uh let's put this to you simon
jones um this is about the idea you know
to allow agency workers to cover for
striking workers the question then asks
that uh when it takes how can that be
allowed to happen when it takes months
to train the signalers the drivers
and sorry i need the question i've got
an auto here but you're not moving
please move the signal is drivers and
guards as well as other specialists is
it not dangerous to go down that road
simon jones
now sorry i missed uh part of that
question devin but the uh you know
safety as you said earlier on uh we have
one of the safest uh train
uh uh operations in the whole of europe
um i know there's more to be done you've
got to keep doing that network rail and
modernizing they've made it safer um in
the way that we maintain our railways
and machines do do this more safely and
accurately they they check for cracks
rather than having i know in the past
you've had people
physically looking at tracks and and
checking it by their eye um and i've
spoken to in the past to uh andrew
haynes the ceo and peter hendy at
network rail they care passionately
about the railway they want it to be a
safer place but we're going to have to
invest and use the technologies which
are now available to them um so that
people are kept out of harm's way
okay indeed um next question this is
about um this is the very point you've
kind of addressed there uh simon calder
is it true that training tube drivers
earn in excess of fifty thousand pounds
a lot of them do yeah i mean what do you
i mean is there any average figure for
overall earnings i'm i'm not forgive me
gonna go there in terms of quoting
averages um it is absolutely the case
that train drivers whether they're on
the tube or whether they're on the
national rail network are very well paid
there is actually quite a lot of tension
between the unions as left which
represents the drivers which is not
involved in this dispute and the rmt
certainly aslef has um uh earned its
members some really um quite handsome
settlements over the past um a few years
for a job which is um highly skilled and
so yes there are some really
significantly high earners on on the
railways but they tend to be doing the
driving and the people working for the r
members of the rmt who tend to be guards
station staff and so on are not on
anything like those levels of pay okay
back to that you touched on this sarah
how does one this is the question how
does one get to glastonbury i don't know
if you're going or not but doesn't it
start on wednesday which is a non-strike
day there will still be disruption on
the trains and i would say and probably
you're going to want to drive you're
going to have a load of equipment and if
you're going to have a disruptive
journey i think most people will move to
the road so set off early i'd say here's
the tester for you simon cola well how'd
you get there by train have you done it
oh yeah you just go to castle carey it's
um a perfectly good um journey there
will be that you know the rail industry
is fully aware of the events that are
happening and they are doing all they
can to get people where they need to be
and please can we give a shout out to
the amazing long distance coach
companies
national express megabus flixbus all of
whom have very professional staff doing
great things keeping people mobile yeah
so plenty of options there if you've got
to go a longer distance as well okay
we're going to take a break you're
watching sky news tonight coming up more
of your questions about the national
rail strikes the biggest industrial
action on the railways for 30 years
[Music]
so we at guide dogs have many
volunteering roles but one of our key
volunteering roles is our puppy raisers
so lovely josephine has brought oaky
today for us to enjoy and he's 17 weeks
okay so a puppy raiser takes on a dog
for us at guide dogs from the age of
about eight weeks until they're about
fifteen years old
they look gorgeous and it's like of
course they can yeah and the role is all
about socializing the puppies getting
the puppies used to things like public
transport and different noises so that
when they go on to form one of our
amazing guide dog partnerships
they're used to all of those things in
the environment and they've spent all
that time there but why would you
um host a puppy and then have to give
him up
the rewarding part of it is a we'll give
you another one so please don't worry so
we yeah we do need more puffy raises so
we're always happy to once you've raised
one puppy we'll provide you with another
puppy to start all over again take my
shoes off and get done with it of course
yeah feel free bless them
no no no don't choose
um but also the reward is
really helping someone to live an
independent life so these dogs go on to
perform an amazing role to be able to
support people as a working guide dog to
be able to have that independence so
okay
really rewarding and do you have to
train them yourself or is it just you
get support so yeah a lot of people so
the research that we did found that
actually 18 of you don't take on a dog
because they feel that they wouldn't
have the knowledge to be able to do that
whereas we have dedicated property
development advisors and supervisors
that help you with that journey to be
able to train those dogs up i'm alex
crawford and i'm skye's special
correspondent based in istanbul
[Music]
[Music]
the inspiration behind our product came
from
understanding how big of a problem
livestock meat and emissions were
welcome back we're answering your
questions about the rail strikes and
general travel disruption this week and
maybe for more weeks to come let's
remind you the details of this week's
industrial action on the railways and
more than 50 000 train workers are
expected to strike
on three days this week strikes will
take place on tuesday thursday and
saturday
but severe delays are expected all week
many companies are telling people to try
to avoid traveling entirely workers in
england will be striking but services in
scotland and wales are also going to be
affected
and these are all the companies that are
involved
the network rail says just over one in
five of the normal number of trains will
run and they'll start later and finish
earlier than usual
the rmt union leading the strike argue
that its members have experienced pay
freezes threats to jobs and attacks on
their terms and conditions and the talks
to try to resolve those issues have
broken down today so uh we've been as i
say putting your questions to our panel
they are the independence travel editor
simon calder sarah nelson from transport
focus and simon jones who's a former
conservative special adviser to the
transport secretary so
next question is this one from a
london-based viewer for the
seven years i've lived in london i don't
believe there has been a single year
without tube strikes how can this
process be sustainable at simon jones uh
those that live in london and travel
into london to work uh more or less know
that i think that's a pretty valid point
i mean the overall question is how can
this be sustainable don't we need to get
not just on you know
tube networks but on the railways don't
we need to get to a position where
there's a long-term solution in place
i think you're absolutely right i mean
we've been hearing from some of those
people on your
uh introduction to this session this
evening uh that people can work from
home but most
uh people that i feel sorry for are
those that need to go into our towns and
cities to earn a living especially in
london the teachers the nurses the
cleaners
the hospitality industry that have been
absolutely decimated during uh covered
times have just got themselves uh back
above the uh water line um people that
are sick and needing a medical
appointment they are just fed up that uh
the rail service every single year in
london has fallen over and the uh
criticism uh i know it's been shoved at
the government but you know this is also
the mayor of london's problem as well
um people need to be able to rely on
public transport every single day
both for themselves and the jobs they
need to go to and the people that are
taking their exams this week who can't
just uh delay for a day or zoom into
their exam process um that's not the way
it's going to work look people's
lifestyles have changed during the
pandemic it's some of that is really
really good but we've got to have a
better more sustainable railway going
forward well and it's therefore it's got
to be able to turn up every single time
we want to use it well i just want to
ask you i mean what about changing the
law did you when you were working with
the transport secretary did you look at
changing the law and i mean outright
banning strikes or certainly designating
it an essential service
well i think this is something we
definitely looked at and you've only got
to look at places like spain who have
got a slightly different approach to it
um and in
in spain you can have a
minimum service requirement which just
means that people that need to do
essential services can still use the
rail network and i think as
part of the modernization as trains get
more uh safe when there are more safety
systems uh on our trains uh we're going
to also have to ask uh unions and my
belief anyway uh to allow people to go
into the jobs they love doing uh whether
that is a driver a conductor catering
staff or the people that
are relying on those trains to get into
our cities to to do the jobs they love
okay well we've got a related question
following on from that asking about well
the technology technology the question
is this already exists to drastically
reduce reliance on this overpaid and
uncooperative workforce don't union
leaders realize that they're only
encouraging the decimation of their own
employment sector
i mean on that issue of technology and
automation the the question is right
simon calder aren't they you know i mean
there are plenty i mean there are
systems in the united kingdom not too
many of them though which are driverless
and conductor-less certainly you can
look at the docklands like railway for
example which is operating tomorrow but
the
understanding is that pretty much
everywhere you want somebody who is
there on board
a member of staff who can who can help
people for instance who needs special
assistance in qatar where of course
they're hosting the world cup they've
opened the most amazing metro which is
driverless but they have staff who are
who are there so you're going to need
staff because passengers want
reassurance they want help and having
something completely automated simply
doesn't work um just on if i may the
london underground tomorrow we have got
another strike um there will be
some services running transport for
london says try and finish your journey
by six if you are
trying to get the tube to run don't
forget that the buses will be incredibly
busy because of course we get two
strikes for the price of one tomorrow in
in the capital um and then do not expect
any tubes to be running before 8am on
they're not so you will be getting
around i think maybe this is
uh we will know an awful lot more by
this time yesterday about how effective
the strikes
yes
not back in time sliding doors um sarah
on that question on that question of uh
staffing and technology from the
passenger perspective of course
passengers they like to see staff at
railway stations is this suggestion of
closing all ticket offices they like to
see staff on platforms they like to see
staff on trains now the pandemic
exacerbated a trend that had started
anyway which is that people
are moving to using the new technologies
and around one in eight tickets are now
sold at the ticket office rather than
the higher proportion before so there is
that however we know that people like to
have staff around they want to know
they've bought the right ticket they
want to know they're in the right place
they want to know someone's there to
help them if they need it and we know
they value those staff
it doesn't matter so much than where
that member of staff is so whether
they're behind a screen or out on the
concourse but they do like to have a
staff presence this is one of those very
tough choices you have to make the idea
that for any journey
you and i should be able to buy a paper
ticket if we want one using the
technology from the 18th century 19th
century is a little bit perplexing when
you're trying to save money yes you can
uh staff all these ticket offices i
remember going to carbus bay previewing
the g7 conference and found that
there's one train every hour the fair is
two pounds and there's somebody sitting
in a hut selling tickets even though you
just need somebody on that
on the train collecting the money or
whatever there are in order to get the
railways on an even keel you are going
to have to make some really tough
choices yeah but plenty millions of
people still don't have smartphones to
there who use that ones as well um let's
get one more question in before uh this
break simon jones uh why are the
government creating a hate campaign in
the media against frontline staff they
worked all through the pandemic yet rail
bosses are on ridiculously high salaries
and still get a rise and bonuses is the
government creating a hate campaign in
your view
uh well i i hope not and i don't think
that that is the case at all i look i
think there is definitely
some tension between the union bosses
and uh
the uh
uh
the talks the network rail and uh
definitely the government at the moment
uh but uh i i love the workers uh on our
system i have always found them
exceptionally approachable um i just uh
sarah was just saying um i'd love to see
uh frontline staff uh speaking to
customers we don't want them in ticket
offices when there's nobody buying
tickets from uh there and they're
getting them either on their phone or uh
from ticket machines um we want to see
more staff i want to see more staff i
really hope that there isn't a campaign
uh either from the public or from
politicians against those people that
are frontline staff what about the
bosses though these high salaries and
bonuses
um well
there are
high paid buses in nearly every sector
um and they're also high paid union
bosses as well and we
the union the rmt i think is sitting on
about
53 million pound at the moment um it
would be quite good if they want their
union members to have more money if they
could dish out some of their own to
their own workers okay as long as the
bosses follow suit
but um be very happy with that too uh
but we uh we want to see but i want to
see better value tickets and the only
way we're going to do that is by making
sure that uh it doesn't become too
costly the prices has all out of our
journeys okay let's take another break
this is sky news coming up more your
questions about the national train
strikes the biggest industrial action on
the railways for yup 30 years
[Music]
welcome back we're answering your
questions about the rail strikes and the
general travel disruption taking place
and uh we've got our expert panel you
know them all by now so
let's continue and uh our next question
this evening is uh about the unions and
and this issue of um
workers
support the work as well as the workers
get the trains as well how can the
unions say they are for the working
people when this strike has disrupted
and cost the working people more during
a cost of living crisis
discuss simon caldwell any trade union
is going to represent the interests of
its workers and the greater the monopoly
status of their industry the more
success they will have and that is why
time and again the railway
unions have
been very active in terms of um
strikes of course
while this is the biggest strike for
three decades on the railways
industrial action has been taking place
in various parts of uh great britain for
decades and really quite frequently and
there are some centuries well but but
there's a lot of action happening quite
a lot for example last year scott rail
um most sundays you simply couldn't get
a a train um that there was simply none
running there's a driver's uh reluctance
to work overtime in scotland which is
still meaning that um some late trains
are are not running so
the unions feel that they have a lot of
power and they are not shy of using it
and sarah on this issue of well you know
the people using the trains you
mentioned that before particularly the
people who have to be at work physically
there's so many people who can't work
from home and they have to use the
trains to get there this is a real
problem it really is and you know
passengers they don't want to think
about the ins and outs of industrial
disputes they just want to go about
their business they want to make their
way to work they want to go and see
people they want to have a social life
you know there's essential journeys sure
but there's also the leisure market
which the rail industry needs to grow if
it's to make a continuous comeback and
if the government is to meet its
sustainability goals so in order to get
people to trust and have confidence in
the railway then the sector needs to get
together and resolve these issues but it
shouldn't be said though should it that
the traveling public is universally
against these strikes you know because
we talk to people as you as you do in a
television news organization you talk to
people who are commuters who do use the
trains to get to work and you know some
of them are saying well you know i know
it's going to be incredibly disruptive
for me but there's some valid points
being made here by the rmt
it is though i think going to feed the
idea of great unreliability and as sarah
was saying you do not want to have
people thinking and look i i say we'll
have questions coming in on this is this
going to carry on all summer answer we
don't know by this time tomorrow we'll
understand you've set my next question
up very nicely which is we need a
resolution don't we simon jones we've
started to explore the foothills of how
we get there here's a very good question
a specific question about maybe this is
a way to avoid the strike certainly why
does it always have to be a strike is
there not a mechanism where the dispute
can be arbitrated and be settled in a
court with legal bindings from the
result for both parties hmm yeah well
i think you made a very good point and
this is an exceptionally good question
obviously there is a way of arbitration
through a cast but look in this process
the negotiations have hardly started i
mean this is not the time for strikes um
and you know
we do need to see a resolution uh it
would be much better if they if the
union leaders and the industry uh could
sit and agree and be arbitrated before
strikes happen the the way that the set
up at the moment works is that they can
call a strike they can uh ask their
members about their members as they did
in april and now cause carnage across
the network and this is going to be
a very difficult few months for the
public and you know not in my lifetime
have we had
high inflation um and this is going to
last into next year and unions from all
sectors want more money we really need
to start with people sitting around the
table rather than by striking uh and
withdrawing their labor yeah i mean
that's outside the remate of this
program at the moment but as you
mentioned these aren't the only strikes
coming down the track so to speak excuse
the plan we get another question in
before we take another break and uh this
is from somebody who works on the
railways i work
for network rail and this isn't just
about a pay rise they're looking to
demolish our terms and conditions and
lay off two and a half thousand people
simon calder as we've been discussing
yeah there's earlier
i understand the uh the sensitivities
i've talked to lots of people who work
on the railway and they they are really
aggrieved voting eight to one in favor
of a strike however um i think there's a
sort of certain uh
amount of believing the union publicity
uh when network rail lasted um
on offer of voluntary redundancies it
was vastly over subscribed the idea that
network rail is just going to go around
and saying right you lot you're you're
out in the manner of piano ferries is i
think most unlikely and furthermore um
the
union began this dispute effectively by
saying we don't want any of our terms
and conditions change when it is
painfully obvious to anybody who travels
on the radio on the railway anybody who
sees what an absolute disaster the
finances are that you're going to have
to change people's terms and conditions
just as in the aviation industry people
are working much harder often for far
less cash um simply because covid has
caused so much harm to the uh the
airlines and the airports aviation
industry and the travelers who use it
coming up in the the next section
another break you're watching sky news
tonight coming up more of your questions
and as i was just saying there we'll be
asking if there's going to be more chaos
and disruption at the airports
some passengers have been left waiting
for hours at many airports after issues
with baggage collection
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i'm hannah thomas peter and i'm skye's
climate change correspondent
the uk is a world leader in wind power
it's part of the congo basin rainforest
which is such an important ecosystem
it's known as the lunds of africa
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
she doesn't really enjoy speaking to the
press and it wasn't clear right up until
the last moment that she was going to
sit down with me i might be just very
naive but i do believe that change is
possible otherwise we wouldn't be
climate activists
[Music]
i'm confident for the last 30 years
we have known how bad it is i'm not here
to apologize i'm here to fight for the
next step
you can see just the piles and piles of
stuff these sofas and people's desks and
children's books and you can see inside
this home here people trying to
to sort out their home it's just been
devastating
i think everything's at stake the future
of our planet the future of this beauty
around us
the future
of you and me
[Music]
welcome back now uh heathrow has asked
airlines to cancel about 10
of their flights to help cope with the
baggage backlog that's building up in
terminal 2 hundreds of passengers had to
wait for over three hours during the
weekend to get their luggage often with
no explanation of course from the staff
and airlines have been given the option
of consolidating their flights as well
well that means that instead of
cancelling 10 percent of the services
they
could move passengers onto other flights
make sure they're entirely full ashna
horinak has more
[Music]
harry and george are meant to be in sao
paulo receiving medical treatment for
their autism but instead they're sat in
heathrow's terminal too trying to get
there after delays force them to miss
their connection their mother carla
feels stranded if i start to explain to
you how i feel i will start crying
the situation from last night to today
this time it's been horrific that's the
only way i can explain to you i
experienced something that i wouldn't
believe i would ever experience with two
autistic kids special needs kids in an
airport that little boy was shaking
shaking and i said please can someone
help me
the airport has asked airlines operating
in two terminals to consolidate their
flights in other words cancel 10 percent
of them to lighten the load colton is
one of nearly 5 000 passengers now
grounded flew from johannesburg to
london hoping to get a connecting fight
also in the morning and when i arrived
here they just got text saying the fight
was canceled pretty much i haven't seen
my girlfriend in 11 months and i'm
proposing to her tomorrow and i was
supposed to see her this morning so that
really
really stinks disruption has lingered as
the industry struggles with the surge in
sun seekers post pandemic problems with
the baggage system at terminal 2 over
the weekend left hundreds waiting for
three hours to collect their luggage
issues with a lack of staff persist
fundamentally the issues that heathrow
are around i.t systems baggage systems
that can't cope coupled with fewer staff
that would normally be on duty due to
the staff shortage across the airports
and airlines and of course it's making a
misery for consumers who are hoping to
have a seamless trip and aren't getting
one
some airlines are trying to get ahead of
further last-minute chaos easyjet has
cut thousands of flights from gatwick
and amsterdam the effect already felt at
schiphol airport where cues snake out of
the terminal building
airlines reducing the number of flights
may be the most sensible option in
delivering a more reliable service over
the summer but it still leaves millions
of passengers panicking about whether
their flights or holidays will be
cancelled or delayed
carla harry and george are now booked on
a flight on wednesday but the delays
have already caused them to miss one
appointment in brazil
a reminder that for thousands of
families this isn't a missed commute or
holiday but a trip they're depending on
ashley harinag sky news
okay well let's get some questions then
about the airlines and the airports of
course they're those baggage problems as
ashna was describing and
this question well has a specific
suggestion
um
sonic holder why don't you use the army
to support baggage handlers at major uk
airports is that that's michael o'leary
i'm sure he he suggested that didn't
either the ryanair boss yes getting
getting the uh
army in making sure that they are
absolutely clear about what needs doing
and so on would be
really um i i i think a very uh last
ditch attempt to deal with something
which ultimately um should be solvable
and probably it's more elegant to cancel
ten percent of your flights than to uh
uh bring in the army anything that
involves working airside in airports is
always going to be very tricky in terms
of security well they'd be securely
cleared though that's part of the
suggestion isn't it well
the security clearance and the security
clearance and what you require to be uh
serving in the military and what you
require to be airside in an airport that
there is not necessarily a complete
congruence between them um certainly i
was down at terminal 2 yesterday i
thought it was a new piece of
performance art uh an early entrant for
the turner prize this is a pile of
bricks in the gym yes this amazing
baggage match yeah the the short answer
for anybody traveling abroad this year
is take cabin baggage only please
because they take it off you at the
gates sometimes as well well not if you
know exactly what the rules are okay so
so um the good thing about that well
exactly you're not gonna have to queue
up for checking you're not gonna have to
wait for the carousel and there's no way
it's going to be sent to the other side
of the world while you're not or indeed
left behind at heathrow okay um a larger
point here and perhaps this is more
generally about strikes this question
wasn't one of the promises that leaving
the eu would see no change in employment
law
simon jones this back to the suggestion
i suppose i suspect the question is
wondering about you know the idea that
the law could be changed to allow agency
staff to replace strikers
i i i think to get to that point you
have to be in a very desperate situation
to do so but agency workers we're not
just talking about uh the untrained
we're talking about very highly
professional people that can come in and
help support at the last minute your
last question was about the uh where the
army should be able to come these are
very highly militarized people that can
uh come in and run things um but they
have to have the skill sets to be able
to do it and
one of the questions which i think i
asked when i was in uh dft was uh
whether uh some of those people that run
freight trains could run passenger
services when we had the problems of
strikes on southern rail uh four or five
years ago
and the answer is generally not so
as much as the headlines are there uh
i'd much prefer people that are
currently doing the jobs to continue
doing the jobs i mean is the government
afraid of exacerbating things you think
i mean you know bringing the army in
it's it's a real signal isn't it
um i think it would be a massive signal
to uh to bring the uh army and i'd much
prefer people to be doing the jobs they
love doing um i don't think it's a great
idea to have the army and although
that said it wasn't it uh
a uh big private company that was
supposed to um ten years ago run the
olympic security and the army was
brought in at the last minute and they
did a terrific job and we had a
brilliant games now that is a last
minute thing to go and do you don't want
to get down to that level um you just
genuinely want um people doing as i say
the jobs that they love doing to get on
with the jobs that they love doing but
of course inflation going to hit 11
maybe higher who knows so last question
we'll get um
sarah nelson on this are we heading for
a summer of discontent with more and
more strikes i mean stay with stay with
the railways because we're only talking
about three days of strikes but we we
heard it have we seen the talks break
down the r t saying this could go on for
many weeks well passengers will
desperately be hope and not they're uh
you know they're ready to come back to
the railway so let's give them something
to come back to everybody needs to get
around the table and hammer out a
solution to this
well i'm afraid the transport salary
staff association have already said that
they want to have a pay rise in line
with inflation well i say i'm afraid
that seems to be from an awful lot of
points of view a perfectly reasonable
thing but as soon as the government
starts handing out nine or ten percent
pay rises well i i cannot quite see that
happening which is why i am
unfortunately
really quite despondent about transport
and the railways this summer simply
because you've got the two sides so far
apart um that i cannot see when they are
going to be able to meet in the middle
sam jones your take on that and the
suggestion of course by the opposition
that the government should get involved
directly in the negotiations
well um
it's not for
government to get in the middle of uh
some things between an employer and an
employee that that sort of ridiculous
and uh i think it was it was it two
weeks ago uh i think the leader of the
rmt made that point that he wasn't even
prepared to go and see the government so
um these are going to be difficult times
inflation as i say in my lifetime has
never been so high um and uh well not
since i was born anyway and i think this
is going to really tax uh people uh who
can't keep up with the cost of living
who are finding it so difficult who will
need uh especially the lower paid and
will need uh pay rises to reflect the
great jobs they do so they can just keep
up and keep on what they're doing uh but
i'm afraid i agree with simon cole's
analysis that this is going to be a very
challenging few months ahead
until people
can bash their heads together and come
up with the right solution and just
beyond that i mean we're not just
talking broadly on strikes
so many other
public sector workers and others
i think that's absolutely right i think
this could uh it could be very dangerous
if
uh people are not willing to talk to
each other and my
my plea to anybody that's working that's
a member of a union is get your bosses
to speak to those people uh
to make sure that we're not uh sitting
um unable to go to the jobs we like
doing okay but instead
are able to have a summer that we can
all enjoy uh after what has been a
tremendously difficult time during kobe
okay well i'm glad to say we've all been
talking to each other thank you all very
much indeed uh simon jones there joining
us from essex sarah nelson and simon
calder here with me in the studio thank
you so much for getting through so many
questions about
the rail strikes which start tomorrow
coming up at 8 much more about those
strikes